[Musik]
der truppenübungsplatz einstieg ist
einer unserer wichtigsten der
verschiedene zwecke erfüllt heute haben
wir gerade gesehen die größte übung
diesem jahr gegeben hat mit deutscher
beteiligung insgesamt
1650 soldatinnen und soldaten die hier
üben und ihr handwerk lernen das ist
notwendig um auch bei internationalen
einsätzen
interoperabilität zu zeigen zu üben auch
dementsprechend zertifiziert zu werden
ich bin beeindruckt von der
einsatzbereitschaft unserer
österreichischen bundesheer
[Musik]
unsere soldaten verdienen sich auch das
beste handwerkszeug dazu zählen gerade
hier am truppenübungsplatz
auch besonders geschützte mobilität und
ich freue mich dass wir heute einiges
über geben durften insbesondere einen
traktor der einzigartig ist weil er in
der führerkabine wirklich min und minen
schutz bietet auch einiges anderes an
gerät das im forst ganz besonders
wichtig ist die herausforderungen sind
groß und unsere
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter und die
soldaten leisten wirklich hier
großartige arbeit